こんにちは現代を生きる黒魔
同士恥で魔女混ぜるデローズ6世だみんな
は魔法というものをご存じだろうか魔法
それは我々魔導士にとっては欠かせない力
魔法を使えばいろんなことができる傷つい
た人を癒すことできるし敵に攻撃をする
こともできたりもう魔導にとっては欠かせ
ない存在なのだよだから現代は令和私が
いるこの世界では魔法が使えないのだMP
というものも存在しない魔力がない時代に
なってしまったのでプラ同士の私は魔法
使えずに困っているんだああどこか
に魔法を使えるようにしてくれる人はい
ないかなそこの気に待ってくださいどうし
ました
あなたジョはジョブ
は科学者科学
者元気先生そうですね元気先生私あの魔導
をしてるんですがこの現実がファイナル
ファンタジーじゃないので元気先生の科学
の力で何度か私に魔法の力を復活させては
くれないだろうかおそんなのはね簡単です
よマジすかはいちに僕どこの世界から来
たかていうとファイナルファンタジーXの
世界から来ましたオンラインのおお
そこそこ強くてマジですか結構その
ファイヤとかブリザードとか初期の魔法
じゃなくて上位魔法とかも使えちゃうん
ですけど大魔法使いなんです大魔法使いな
んです実はそっかでも大丈夫ですかね科学
を使えば不可能はないと思ってるんでおお
ちょっと一緒に考えながらやってき
ましょうよ助かりますというわけで今日は
車
同士名前なんだっけ私と科学者先生のお力
をお借りしてファイナルファンタジーの
世界の魔法をどれぐらい再現できるのか
やってみたいと思います行きましょう
はいはじめさんどんな魔法使えるんですか
僕はそうです
ねまあファイナルファンタジーXの世界に
いた時ははい結構何でも使えたんですけど
もおまキス的なものから行くとファイアと
かですかねファイアはいあの炎の魔法
ちょっとあの弱めというか結構初期で覚え
ちゃったやつなんですけど初期で覚えた
はい現代だとファイアって結構難しいん
ですよねあそうなんですかうん炎系でも
それからやってみましょうかぜひお願いし
ますまじゃ使うものはですね現代の科学で
はえニトロセルロースを使っていき
ましょうニトロセルロースロースカツ
みたいですねえ火薬ですね
だこちらにはい火薬があります
えファイア使えるんですよねあもちろん
ですもう1つ使うのがこれもね同じ火薬の
紙です火薬の紙はいやべえ魔法
怖えあれちょっと魔法使ってる時と感覚
違うんですかねそうそうそうですねやっぱ
こう発射する感じがいいですよねいやまあ
攻撃魔法なんで発射はしたいですねうん
うんうんうんちょっとじゃあやっていき
ましょうかおこれがついにファイヤーはい
おやってきましょうちょっとファイヤーの
杖を持ってきますねファイヤーの杖お願い
しますはい
さあ作っておきましたよおおファイヤの杖
よいよファイナルファンタジーっぽくなっ
てきましたねはい今ちょっと充電してたら
折れちゃいましたけど先っぽがね飛ばすの
は火薬の綿それを発射するために使うのが
火薬の紙これがあればいけるんじゃないか
なとなるほどなるほどはいちょっとじゃあ
折り曲げていただいてはいくるくるっと
巻きますねはいよしよしよしよしよしはい
じゃここに詰めてくださいはい詰めます
はいよじゃさらにこれを詰めてくださいお
分かりました詰めちゃいます
はい気のせいなのか折れておりますあれ
テープくれるあ
ありがとうあれきつすぎ
た
うおうお
うおあええええ電源が入ってまし
たちょっと待ってくださいはい今の魔法
ですか先今の魔法ですねくそはいあの先生
自分にファア飛んできたりする可能性はあ
0ですあ良かっただったら安心ですそうし
ちょっとね大丈夫かな大丈夫ですよねええ
え大丈夫で大丈夫でしたね大丈夫でした
良かったです
よし魔法こええ準備完了ですねはい
ありがとうございますはいこれでもう魔法
打てますのでこれでもうファイヤーが出て
しまうとはいファイヤーが出ますんで気を
つけていただいて分かりましたじゃ行き
ますね先生もうちょい離れていいですはい
はいこええファイヤ炎魔法の一番弱いやつ
ですよね弱いやつですね初歩的
なじゃあ行き
ますファイヤ
ファイヤーファイヤー
[音楽]
ヤ
うわあかわされましたまでも突き抜けたの
かもしれない突き抜けてました今完全
に吹き抜けてましたファイナル
ファンタジー14の世界で見たファイヤと
同じでしたファイヤのねなんかボール飛ん
できましたよねすげえおおまずは第1段階
ね初歩的な魔法でしたねいやでもクリア
ですこれいや僕でもファイアとかも使いて
なんですけどももうちょっと強いやつあの
炎属性魔法のファイガとかもファイガ
ファイガも使えてましたもうちょっと強い
んです
[音楽]
けど相当レベル高いですねかなり上位の
魔法にはなってるんですけどちょ自分が
ダメージ食らう可能性高くなりますけど
大丈夫です
かやりますかやりますじゃあ使うものはえ
大量の火薬えっと先生これ行くとぶわって
いきますんで両で攻めましょうなるほど
これ
と水素えっと水素よく燃える機体ですね
そうですねぶわっていう爆発するイメージ
はありますそうですね
あとガソリンガソリンぶわっていきます
からねそうですね先生今のところ3のバっ
ていくやつです力技ですファイガってね
対象に当たった時にバンバンバンバンバン
爆発しますからねそうはいあの辺に置い
といてでここから遠くから火つけましょう
か分かりましたじゃ準備してきましょう
はいここにじゃあ洗場に細かく細く
貼り付けてってもらえれば分かりました
[音楽]
はいこれやばいんちゃうん
けはいあありいますえっと先生すごい量が
追加されこれは大変なこと
に近先生が大変なことになると本当に大変
なことになるんだよなよし然晴れました
ほいあいい感じですねじゃちょっとあとは
水素ですね水素はいこの風船を作ります
はい穴が開いております穴なんか水素って
怖いイメージありますうん水素爆弾みたい
なあそうですね確かに水素これだけ燃える
とねなきますんでえもうこれも燃えると
やばいですかこれやるとボンっていでああ
無理だしかもこのサイズやったことないん
でちょっとどうなるのか楽しみですこの
サイズやったことないからどうなるか
楽しみはいじゃあこの辺にいてもらって
はいじゃあしっかりこれを止めといて
もらっていいですか分かりましたあ
ばっちりすねうんこれでボってなるわけ
ですねそうですねボっていってバーンって
いくっていうのをちょっとあと2つくらい
くっつけましょうか分かりはいギオ
だらけじゃホワイトガソリンホワイト
ガソリン火力足しましょうかしましょう
これでちょっとこうなんすかねこういう
感じ
でもうちょっと広げてきましょうかあ
わかりました
はいどうでしょ先生いいっすねありがとう
ございますこれやばいぞこれどうなるん
いやもう先生俺やる前から分かってます
これやばいです多分やばいすか離れ
ましょうこれやばいすねこれでね準備完了
です準備完了しまし
たやりましょう先生そんなに届かないす
多分これではいあもう大丈夫ですかなんか
みんな離れてきますはいすごい距離離れて
ますけどスタッフがまあ多分大丈夫
でしょう分かりました準備はいいですか
準備大丈夫ですちょっと僕はダメージ
食らった時ように用意してきますんで
助かります何やるかわかりませんから消す
ようにね行き
[音楽]
ます
う
ファイガ
ファイガうわ
う燃え燃えたぎった先生ファイガですこれ
は行けますねずっと燃えてる先生僕結構
あの多彩な魔法使いましてお他に何使うん
すか僕あの雷魔法の方もちょっと結構ける
口雷魔法はいあのサンダー
サンダー電撃の魔法使えちゃったりし
ちゃうんですけどはいはい現代で
それできますかねそうですね現代の社会だ
とねここ何もないところから電気起こす
のって難しいのでなるほどなるほど
ちょっとラボに行けば電気がありますので
あわかりましたそこでやってみませんか
はいぜひよろしくお願いしますじゃお願い
しますはいでは移動しましょうはい
おおここが元先生のラボですかはいよう
こそ僕のラボへお越しいただきました
ありがとうございます多分初めて来ました
あそうですよねそういえば何回かちょっと
僕がお邪魔することあってもこちらに来て
いた初めてですねえそうなんですよいつも
来ていただいててちょっとお邪魔します
はいこうだったらどんな実験でもできます
のでどんな実験ってことは僕がファイナル
ファンタジーの世界でやってたサンダーと
かもサンダーはいはい簡単にきますマジす
かやらしてくださいサンダーやりましょう
かはいお願いしますはいサンダー用の杖は
こちらですねおおなんかかっこいいぞ今回
金属ですかそうですねやっぱ電気を貯める
にはやっぱ金属が一番いいのでね金属性の
杖を作ってみましたこの杖を使ってサンダ
が起こせるということですねそうですね
ほうあともう1つ使うものがまこの現代の
科学を使うとなると静電器静電機はいそれ
を使っていきます使う装置がねこちらです
へえ
これあの対電がと言ってですねこっから
あの静電機出ますのでここでえ電気を貯め
て放射するとなるほどなるほどはいじゃあ
ちょっとそこに電気を貯めるたにここ止め
ますねはいこれで魔力を充電できるとそう
ですね現代科学でいう静電機というものを
この杖とはじめさん全体に貯めますえっと
はじめさん全体に僕も混ざってましたが
やべえ俺結構魔法の中で31番怖いすんだ
よ
な貯めてきますかはいではスイッチオンえ
ビリビリ言ってる全身に雷のマリを感じる
来てます来てます溜まってますねこれ
やばいマジでサンダーだこれ溜まってき
てる感じがするすごいなんか電気まとっ
てる本当にいいすねはいいい感じです
ありがとうございますじゃサンダーの魔法
お願いします行きますはいお願いし
ます
サンダーああああれ自分自分サンダーです
かこれ自分サンダーあどうでしたバチンて
ちょっと痛かっちょっと痛かったですあ金
君とか持ってますか持ってましたちょっと
だけあちょっとだけあしっかり持ってて
いいたあ分かりましたはいどうですか
サンダ
え危険な魔法でし先生これ僕思ったんです
けどやっぱりその僕が使ってる魔法って
戦闘用のバトル用の魔法なのでちょっと
実践を踏まえてそのモンスターに試してみ
たいですモンスターにまあまあこれだっ
たら大丈夫ですサンダくらいならあはい
ちょっとどのくらい強いのか見てみ
ましょうか見てみたいですはいえ生き物は
どちらにあじゃそこのモンスターを使い
たいです
モンスター出てきたモンスターこの
モンスターを使ってちょっとサンダ売って
みたいです分かりましたやってみましょう
ちょっとサンダーの実際の威力をね試して
もらってこれ持ってもらってはい金属を
ギっ
とじゃあエネルギーを食べますよしお願い
します
はいあてめ来た来た来た来たおおた好きな
場所めけてンダこれどこでも大丈夫なん
ですかどこでもああの眼球とかはやめて
りさ行くぞモンスター
くらえ黒魔法
[音楽]
サンダ来
たビクトリーあおお先生はいでは雷魔法の
上位魔法サンダガお願いします
サンダガサンダ側まずこちらを使い
ましょうはいあれなんかまたひきは
いかつい杖がちょっと気になってるんです
けどこの装置は一体これは50万ボ発生さ
せるテスラコイルというものですねなんか
聞いたことあるなはいということでここ
からあの雷見えますのでこれを近づいとい
てくれればはいこう雷が出ているように
見えますんでなるほどやってみますかお
願いしますはいこはじゃちょっと一応ね
え適当に適当にはいひしの役割ですねこれ
がないと自分のとこに流れてきますんで僕
ってことですかそうですねなんでこれ命綱
みたいなもんなんで外れないように気を
つけてくださいさっき適当にって
えいきますかはいで
はサンダが唱えてください
さが
やどうでしたえ焦げてる先生ちょっとサダ
が綺麗に見たいのではい暗くしてもいいん
ですかそうですねもうちょっと暗くすると
太く見えるようになりますね
おおはいはいはいはい来た来た来た来た
いいですかはいお願いしますはいでは呪文
を唱えて
くださいサダ
[音楽]
がいい感じ怖え先生はいサダ怖いですサダ
ってこういうもんなんすねいやすごいサダ
でした本当に大成功ですね大成功ですはい
良かったですただ先生あの
僕まだ魔法使えるのがありまして氷の魔法
のブリザドブリザド
はいブリザド好きなんですかプリザード氷
の魔法結構使っちゃうんですけども結構
冷たいのでなんですからできたりするん
ですかねそうですねやってみましょうか
いけるんですか多分科学の力を使えば
ちょっとぜひブリザードも再現したです
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますブリザードはどうやって再現するの
でしょう
かブリザードの魔法用にすげえ完成しまし
たこちらですえぐいこれが氷魔法用の杖
ですねそうですねでここに氷魔法の
エネルギー溜まってますんですげえはい
めっちゃかっこいいちょっとこれだけあの
サイズ大きめになってますがそうですね
いろんな関係ではいやっぱ杖は色々あり
ますからそうですねじゃあ行きます
[音楽]
はい
プリズカメラマンに大ダメージこれは倒せ
そうですね倒せそうですねモンスター登場
してもらいますモンスターお願いし
ますこれが訓練用のモンスターですました
よしじゃ早速攻撃してみますね
はい
ブリザド
よし凍らせた
すごいビクトリ
これすごいですねねこれいい感じにでき
ましたよでも人気先生
僕結構魔法の鍛錬しててあのブリザドの上
のはいうんブリザがブリザが
[音楽]
はい氷魔法のもっと強いやつとかちょっと
できたら嬉しいかなっていうこれより強い
のとかできるんですか結構意欲強かった
ですけどそうですねでじゃあこちらにあの
マイナス200°の液体窒素というものが
ありますんでなるほどマイナス200です
かそうですねもうブリザですねそれそう
ですねじゃあ先生よろしくお願いします
行きましょうか見た感じ先生と僕で入れて
バーンて感じですそうですねもうこの空間
全部ちょっと凍らせちゃいましょうおおと
なると杖を振った瞬間にバンってなって
欲しいので入れる役をちょっとモンスター
にお願いしたいですあ了解ですモンスター
いけるか
毎回違うタイプだなじゃあちょっとお湯を
入れますねはいオケほだよお湯を入れるん
だ
おさあ火傷しないように気を
つけろいきなりやら
れるけ方がわかすいませんちょっとIQが
低いちょっと行きます氷
魔法
ブリザうわ
ああやばい先生どうだ寒いいやすげえです
先生これすごいですこれこれはブリザが
成功です大成功
あれ
モンスター
ビクトリーすいません威力が強すぎて
モンスター倒してしまいました手伝って
もらったのに手伝ってもらったのに申し訳
ないこれで結構僕が使ってた魔法はほぼ
再現できたと思うんですけどあ本当ですか
もう満足しましたかただ俺もう1個だけ
秘密の魔法を覚えてまして
はいメテオメテオはいメテオというその
隕石をぶちおとすはいやばい
魔法
最強の魔法をちょっと覚えてるんですけど
もすごいっすねはいその隕石をふらす魔法
とかって先生できたりしますかねちょっと
成功するかわかんないですけどやってみ
ましょうかあお願いしますさっきの場所
行きましょうかオです分りました行き
ましょう行き
ましょうはいというわけで再び外に戻って
きましたはい先生
メテオなんてできるんですかいいアバに
ちょうどいいメテオを打ちますかあいい
メテオでお願いしますちょっと今からやる
のは酸か鉄っていうものとアルミニウムの
粉はいこ混ぜてですね火をつつけると大体
3000度ぐらいの熱を持つですよ思った
より高いですね頑張れば使える最大の温度
3000度ぐらいええを目指していきます
なるほどなんかそのファイアとか
ブリザードとかサンダーってまあまあまあ
なんか価格でできそうみたいなはいあるん
ですけどメテを再現した科学者は多分い
ないと思いますよそうですね僕もこれを
やってる動画とかなんか世界中
YouTubeで探したんですけど1人も
いなくてあの安全かどうかもわかんない
ですけどね先生やってきますかはい早速
準備していきましょうはいあの粉吸い込む
といけないんでねあそっかそれもう吸っ
たらやばいですか吸ったらあの爆発し
ちゃうかもしんないのでやばじゃ粉をここ
に入れちゃってください分かりました入れ
ます
じゃ一旦半分入れていただいて半分はい
はいでこっちがあのアルミの粉アルミの粉
はい白いねじゃこれを混ぜてください
わかりました
はい行き
ます混ぜますうわあ混ざってき
た追加していきますよ
はい
やばい量
があ言い忘れたんすけどはいこれあの火
ついたらすぐ逃げてくださいねここにい
たら溶けて蒸発しちゃうんで本当に怖い
ですもう準備が整ってるってことです準備
整ってますえ
怖いシュってっ
[笑い]
たらどうですかねいや結構混ざった気がし
ますおおじゃあこれを入れますか入れ
ましょうはい
これで100kg
よし行きますはいせーの
行けうわ
やばい
わ
おやばいっすねうわ
やばい火薬の中にいるやばさ確かに今け
たら溶けちゃう完全にましたねこれでに
しまったともー
ワンバケツもうワンバケツ行きましょう
行きましょう全部入れちゃっていいっすね
はい入れちゃって
くださいもうワンバケツ作り
ますおおいい感じですねありがとうござい
ますちょっと全全MP先に使うってやつ
ですねこれはすせHPもなくなりますHP
も入れますか入れましょうせーせーのう
うわあよしよしよしよしよし
よしいい感じですよしじゃああとは隕石を
落としてここに着火するだけですねついに
来ましたかついに来ましたこの世界を破滅
に導く日がですねはいというわけで元気
先生山の上まで来ましたねそうですねはい
すごい防具していただいてはいちょっと
あの危ないと聞いたのでスタッフも含め
元気先生の僕もしっかり安全の元魔法
メテオさせていただきますこれは何ですか
先生あそうですねこれ今メテオ用意しまし
たメテオ中にですね鉄の網が入ってるん
ですねはいはいはいその周りに包帯巻いて
あってこれに灯油を染み込まして火がつい
たメテオが飛んでくじゃないですかおお
ロベというかこれを使ってそうですねこの
ワイヤーを使って木のついた球が飛んで
いってあそこにイカしないかなというはい
あでメテオがあそこに入ったらバーンって
ことですうわっていう感じですげえあそこ
にクレーターを作ってあげようというとこ
ですねうわぜひよろしく願いしますはい
じゃちょっとここに灯油をかけて火の玉を
まず作りましょうはいわかりましたじゃあ
行きます
はいさあしっかりと燃えてくれよ満面なく
自分にはかけないようにはい分かりました
自分ごとメテオになっちゃうからねそう
ですねやばいこんなたっぷりつけていいん
ですか先生まこのくらいでいいすかねはい
はいいい感じでしょうよしよしよしよし
よしじゃあこれをはいかけますねお願いし
ますはい
よいしょおしおおすげえはいはいはい
やべえ
マジあのメテオの威力がちょっとはい予想
外に強かった場合なんか色々飛んでくると
思いますのであのこう避けてください
分かりましたうさっき縦渡されたんです
けどあそうですねそこがあればま
プラスチックだから多分鉄が飛んできても
貫通しないでしょ分かりましたでは大魔法
メテオ行きますインカお来た来た来た来た
来たよしよしよしよし過ぎました行き
ます魔法メテオ離します
行け行かない行け行
た
行け
行け行け
おお
ちょっと
行け何かが引っかかってるちょっとじゃれ
てもいいですかはい
どうぞおいおい
おメテオが上下に動いてるメテオ
メテオもう入りそう入って落として
おいしょ行け落として
おいしょはいおやばいうお出
た
[音楽]
痛めてよ
えぐい
[音楽]
これがメテオだなんか燃え方すごくない
ですかもうマグマがグツグツしてますね
行ってみますか行ってみ
ましょううわやっばちょっと待って中
やばいあの金属のメテオが後方もないです
[音楽]
ねバーンはいというわけで現先生
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ましたいやすごい大変でしたねいや大変
だったけどなんか再現度結構ちゃんと高く
てめっちゃ感動しましたはいいやFFね
面白いですもんねもいっぱい見込んで
できるだけ近くしましたねいやもうメて
怖かったですもん現実世界でやろうとする
とああいうハプニングもつき物ということ
でそうですね色々簡単に魔法でピッていく
わけじゃないですねはいとわけで皆さん
オンラインRPGのファイナル
ファンタジー14遊んだことあります
でしょうかあの僕もちょっとだけやった
ことあるんですけれどもオンラインなので
世界がめっちゃ広くで遊び方がすごい色々
あるんですよオンラインなんでで私はじめ
社長サブチャンネルはじめ社長2の方で
実際にファイナルファンタジーXで遊んで
みているのでそちらの動画是非チェックし
てみてくださいそしてファイナル
ファンタジーXなんとレベル70まで無料
で遊びますすごえこれスクエアエニクス
さんにお聞きしたんですけども普通の
ゲーム3本分らしいんですよすごいっすね
驚きの無料で遊べるボリになってるので皆
さんよかったら是非ファイナル
ファンタジーX遊んでみてください詳しい
内容は動画の概要欄にあります先生
ファイナルファンタジー14の世界には
まだ色々魔法がたくさんあるのでなんか
特殊な魔法あったらまたぜひぜひぜひうん
もうこれのやっぱ1000倍くらいやり
たいですよね次
はこの世が終わっ
[音楽]
ちまう
お